can you tell us a little bit about what
it was
here when you had your problematic
neighbors I didn't want to come home
every night I work really long shifts on
my job but it obviously your home is
your haven but the problem we were
having I just didn't want to come home
because we found people slept in the
hallway as soon as we come in the door
the be music thumping would be shouting
lots of noise just you just didn't feel
safe in your own home you know I come
home and lock the door even with Italian
they've been noise you just couldn't
ever get to sleep it was never I don't
think we were months and months months
without sleep and it got so bad that we
moved back to my parents for six months
because we just couldn't couldn't switch
it off they'd have the same song on
repeat 12 I was straight I try read in
my bedroom you know what a weekend just
I just couldn't get there was no time to
switch off and the type of people they
were they weren't people that you could
approach you kind of asked them to stop
because when we did complain they
started knocking on our doors and said
they were going to do all sorts of nasty
things to us with hammers and just just
awful drop kicking off front door and
pretty often we'd end up calling the
police sometimes two or three times a
night just never ever felt like you can
relax in your own home and when you work
long hours like I do you want to come
home and relax in help me on a timer I
think she had five boyfriends and every
single one was the same caliber a person
either drugs drink mental health
problems and you can never ever feel
safe in your own home when you'll
finding drunk people or yeah you know or
intoxicated people actually outside your
front door when the different agencies
were made aware obviously we went for a
closure order and close the property
went to court can you tell us a little
bit about what life is like now here the
minute she was gone from that first
close your order and all her friends
that stayed at her one bedroom flat that
sometimes she had success staying there
a night that would just stay there
intermittently for months at a time one
of the closure order was granted life
normal overnight the weight lifted
stress levels went down you know got
back into a sleeping pattern I know it
sounds things you take for granted
really you know to come home at night
and be able to make witty and not feel
you know I don't know what's going to
kick off tonight it you know it was
wonderful absolutely wonderful but you
know the closure order the first one you
know as I say every time we got them it
was um you know rapid kind of weight
lifting it really and you know the
police are now setia paper officers if
it wasn't for them I don't know where we
were being out I really don't know I
need have knelt break down my marriage
just very very stressful sleeve that
that's now dissolved and I really think
that the pressures of having all this
next door really didn't help it can you
tell us a little bit now about I mean
obviously you had to go through the
court procedure and that's a very
difficult thing for us to have to ask
you to do can you tell us what you would
say and what advice you would give to
other people who find themselves in a
similar situation to you there is help
out there it might not happen overnight
it might take lots of phone calls lots
of letters but once these people are on
board they're there to help you and
support you I don't know how many emails
and phone calls I made to the police and
the annotation paper team but every time
once they were on board it was catered
for and helped along the way in my case
there was no short-term solution but
they kept they knew that and they kept
helping and helping and helping and
after I think three closure orders and
an extension she actually decided to
sell the property so through persistence
and I got my life back brilliant thank
you very much for speaking to us